what you're looking at isn't some weird
x-ray it's actually a baby yellow tank
surgeonfish at 2 months old and you
thought your childhood was awkward but
here is the same fish as an adult a
beautiful inhabitant of the Indian and
Pacific Oceans coral reefs and one of
the most popular captive fish for
saltwater aquariums of the 27,000 known
fish species over 1/4 live on coral
reefs that make up less than 1% of the
Earth's surface but prior to settling
down in this diverse tropical
environment baby coral reef fish faced
the difficult process of growing up on
their own undergoing drastic changes and
the journey of a lifetime before they
find that reef to call home the life
cycle for most of these fish begins when
their parents spew sperm and eggs into
the water column
this can happen daily seasonally or
yearly depending on the species
generally following lunar or seasonal
tidal patterns left to their fate the
fertilized eggs drift with the currents
and millions of baby larvae hatch into
the world when they first emerge the
larvae are tiny and vulnerable some
don't even have gills yet and must
absorb oxygen directly from the water
through their tissue thin skin they may
float in the water column anywhere from
minutes to months sometimes drifting
thousands of miles across vast oceans
far from the reefs where they were born
along the way they must successfully
avoid predators obtain food and ride the
bright currents to find their way to a
suitable adult habitat which might as
well be a needle in a vast haystack of
ocean so how did they accomplish this
feat until recently marine biologists
thought of larval fish as largely
passive Drifters dispersed by ocean
currents to distant locales but in the
last 20 years new research has suggested
that larvae may not be as helpless as
they seem and are capable of taking
their fate in their own fins to maximize
their chances of survival
the larvae of many species are
unexpectedly strong swimmers and can
move vertically in the water column to
place themselves in different water
masses and preferentially ride certain
currents these fish may be choosing the
best routes to their eventual homes when
searching for these homes
ever
suggests that larvae navigate via a
complex suite of sensory systems
detecting both sound and smell odor in
particular allows larvae to distinguish
between different environments even
adjacent reefs helping guide them toward
their preferred adult habitats many will
head for far-flung locales miles away
from their birthplace but some will use
smell and other sensory cues to navigate
back to the reefs where they were born
even if they remain in the larval stage
for months so what happens when larvae
do find a suitable coral reef do they
risk it all in one jump from the water
column hoping to land at exactly the
right spot to settle down and
metamorphose into adults not exactly
instead larvae appeared to have more of
a Bungie system larvae will drop down in
the water column to check out a reef
below if conditions aren't right they
can jump back up into higher water
masses and ride on chancing that the
next reef they find will be a better fit
but this is the point where our
knowledge ends we don't know the
geographic movements of individual
larvae for most species nor do we know
which exact environmental cues and
behaviors they use to navigate to the
reefs they will call home but we do know
that these tiny trekkers are more than
the fragile and helpless creatures
science once believed them to be the
secret lives of baby fish remain largely
mysterious to us unknown adventures
waiting to be told